one of those is Lynn Dalton who has
terminal cancer and so will be in
isolation good morning to you it's very
difficult under under any circumstances
particularly under yours what are you
getting well I will be seeing my
children today I've got today I don't
particularly want to flap the rules but
this is probably going to be their last
Mother's Day my plans obviously I could
until now had been to keep going as long
as I can keep going but without the
benefit of being able to go out and do
what limited things I could do that's
going to be very difficult
it's incredibly personal and difficult
can I ask you what your prognosis is in
terms of of how long I actually don't
know I believe it to be maybe 3-4 months
right I mean I was looking at the
government advice yesterday last night
and it's it does say that if you have a
terminal condition with the prognosis of
six months or less you may wish to
ignore these rules but they're saying
that's and you know entirely a personal
decision entirely up to you but they are
sort of saying if you want to you can
does that change your perspective a
little it does change my perspective
somewhat however of no I've no desire to
put other people at risk so you know
visitors to my home are welcome I will
do my best not to go out and and expose
other people but yes it does change my
perspective someone certainly can
imagine quite what goes through your
head at a time like this when obviously
you've you know you've been dealing with
the terminal diagnosis but then on top
of this there are these other problems
that come into play how are you staying
strong or are you staying strong I think
I am staying strong I've got a great
support network I've got wonderful
children I've got some great sisters and
an extended family who were all grew
what I'm trying to do and I persuaded
myself of this a few days ago is not to
view this as a 12-week period but to
take it in smaller chunks and doing that
finding myself activities that I can do
inside my home craft activities painting
drawing that little thing and try and
focus on the net through four days and
then onto the net three or four days
beyond that rather than watch 12 weeks
stretch out ahead of me I'm fine
I'd be nowhere in the last 12 weeks yeah
it's a long it is a long time are you is
there an element then in which you can
stay positive by sort of say well I'm
gonna maybe I'll do some arts and crafts
next week or do some painting or
whatever it might be whatever floats
your boat is that it is it actually
possible to stay quite positive if you
adopt to that sort of mindset for me I
think so it won't work for everyone but
for me I think though and that actually
that's what's kept me going through the
last 12 months when I've known my
diagnosis my prognosis
um focusing on the shorter term try and
do this in the next few days try and do
that in the next few weeks um and and
yes I believe that is what helped me
stay beautiful yeah at least now with
this I mean I would I would advise you
to look at the stuff on the government
website rather than just listen to me
but with the advice that I saw on the
government website last night saying
actually your children would be able to
come and visit you if you decided if you
decided to do that I mean that that
hopefully would be you know quite some
cool some comfort in thinking that you
can see them through out your last few
months yeah absolutely
Lynne I can't tell you how much I admire
you your stoicism and even coming onto
the program this morning it fills me
with admiration I wish you all the very
best and I hope that you do get to spend
your lots of quality time with your
family and with your kids particularly
thank you so much for talking to us
you're very welcome
you